they don't have YouTube multiple people
at once
hi hi - Matt's Pio nice to meet you
I know you guys a lot haha thank you so
much tell your friends to subscribe and
drive right yeah we're trying to break
leave a comment so we had a guy one time
a CEO who's a new CEO he just been
transferred he calls this other guy in
to the office he walks by it was a older
guy
what older white guy he calls this other
white guy ain't to it with an inmate
into his office he goes hey uh how long
you been here he's I haven't been here a
while about three years about three
years you know you can't called in the
CIO's office is not good mm-hmm it's
like you know God you walk out guys like
what would y'all talk about like are you
telling on people or why he's innocent
why are you you know yeah so he's so
he's like three years he goes yeah he
said uh how old do you you know about 60
it's like whatever his age was he's like
and the CEO was probably in his late
probably early sixties yeah yes well you
work out work out you know you're in
pretty good shape he's like huh I work
out I work out he's like yeah I work out
yeah he said at that point I started
going the [ __ ] is going on just hitting
on this guy sizing him up yeah so he
said it got to the point where he
they're having a conversation and then
he said out of the blue the CEO says you
know if you have set if you're in prison
you have sex with another man it doesn't
make it gay and he goes yeah it does you
know people do things in prison they
wouldn't normally do he is not me not me
he said look I gotta go and he walks off
so he comes and tells me and I go holy
[ __ ] he's like yeah I don't feel good
about that no God I looked at him I went
[ __ ] so then I'm going I talked to my
buddy Pete Rossini Rossini so we're down
there and I go tell him what happened he
goes man listen all this [ __ ] so he
tells us all as me Pete and some other
guy weird
we're talking and so Pete looks at me
and looks at and we're all looking each
other and I go
honestly that may be your get out of
jail free cards you guys are [ __ ]
here's where me and I went I'm just
saying don't be so quick to turn this
guy down and and and he goes hey [ __ ]
you I go what I'm just saying look what
it's a big deal I said you give him a
reach-around and Pete go save the sample
he's like quit [ __ ] around cliff I go
bro you got a lot of time it's just not
looking good your case ain't going well
I'm gonna admit that whole [ __ ] 20
bit understand I'm just saying what's
the big deal then what's he saying
nobody's gonna say anything I'm not
gonna judge you Pico I won't judge you
I mean you're yes and I pocket you
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you can blow the
prison guard for save ten years of your
life would you do it I'll do the time
would you really are you [ __ ] serious
[Music]
I might jacket dude off for ten years
you know blow a blow job that's bad I
don't know if I definitely [ __ ]
wouldn't do that million years to give a
[ __ ] prison guard to jack off a
prison guard to save ten years of your
life you wouldn't do it rather kill miss
you wouldn't Jack dude gonna kill
himself that's the real gay guy guys
would be like whenever he missed three
years County three years off your
sentence they're like three years off
your city with you and I'd be like no no
no they go what if nobody had to know I
bet I know dude 20 okay 20 years 20
years 20 20 you what you if you if they
listen God came down from heaven you
said of Shane listen the way to shut up
if gosh our nation hang on oh I'm making
it up if you're in prison and [ __ ]
God come down from heaven in prison for
20 years
okay I'm
God comes down says Shane if you Jack
this guy off you're a free man you don't
have to do 20 years no chance bro no
you're doing you're doing that you're
doing 10 or 20 you're doing 10 or jack
some guy off or you're doing 20 no no
you're doing 20 or you jack off the card
and you walk out and you're walk out no
time [ __ ] that
no way you're doing 20 no way I'd rather
do 20 I'm saying I jack off guard out of
gate I jack off
[Laughter]